Fear, alienation, and loneliness: these are
the emotions that Rahmat associates with Kabul.
Last December, the 23 year-old returned here
on the first deportation flight from Germany,
where he'd lived for six years.
He's afraid to show his face, for fear of
the Taliban, from whom he had fled at the
time.
"The Taliban murdered my father, because he
was a famous general - that's why I fled.
If they find me, they'll kill me too.
I'm afraid.
It's not safe here."
Rahmat looks at pictures from Germany.
He misses his friends from the vocational
school he attended until 2012, when his asylum
application was rejected.
Migration officials didn't believe his story,
and four years later they deported him.
"It's not fair - after six years there, we
were integrating.
I learned the language, I did training.
It was never easy, but we did it, and I think
it's wrong that they would simply kick us
out."
Today he has an appointment at the aid organization
AMAZO.
Its founder, Abdul Ghaffoor willingly went
back to Afghanistan a few years ago.
Now he's helping deportees like Rahmat, providing
counseling and emotional support, and helping
them find work.
"They are in a situation that they do not
know where to go.
They don’t have families.
They do not have a network here.
They don’t know how to find work.
They're afraid of the security situation - So
yes you're sending people back to nothing
- as a result, what happens is that because
they don’t have anything here.
They don’t find hope; they don’t find
any mean of survival.
What happens - as soon as they are deported
back, they leave the country again."
Rahmat is staying with friends.
But it's hard for him; he doesn't want to
burden them.
And he doesn't dare to return to his home
in Ghasni.
He doesn't know where his mother and brother
are living.
Like many refugees, he's lost contact.
"I've tried to locate my mother, but I just
don't know where she is.
I don't even know if she's alive or dead."
Fleeing to Europe again isn't an option for
Rahmat.
He doesn't have the money to pay the smugglers.
And he has no prospects either.
For now, he exists in a vacuum, neither welcome
in Germany nor Afghanistan, living somewhere
between the past and the present.